ich finds echt mega cool wenn meine
zuschauer einfach auf meinen videos
nehmen daraus irgendwelche beste auf
zusammenschneiden
die sind dann entweder auf instagram
twitter oder youtube hochladen meter zu
schicken sich freuen wenn ich dann
leider gäbe oder darauf antworte aber
was jetzt vor ein paar wochen passiert
ist ja das wird sich so cool ich will
gar nicht lange drum rum jetzt
wahrscheinlich eh schon der titel
gelesen
deswegen würde ich sagen zeige ich euch
mal direkt eine mail die ich vor einiger
zeit zugeschickt bekommen habe und zwar
hat mir der maximilian am zweiten mai
2017 um 1 uhr 24 ich weiß nicht wieso er
mir das um halb zwei nachts geschickt
hat habe auf jeden fall eine mail
geschickt mit dem betreff deine videos
auf pornoseiten ja ich lese euch die
welt einfach mal vor und zwar hallo luca
habe eben durch zufall eins deiner
videos auf einer pornoseite gefunden
wieso und warum ist ja auch egal im
anhang noch einen screenshot lieben gruß
max und dann habe ich halt in den
anderen der mehr geguckt und habe dort
diesen screenshot gefunden
german team bondi beach no sex ich weiß
nicht wer welche website das war weil
ich diese screenshots von der mail schon
halb vor zwei wochen gemacht habe
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht wir
schauen jetzt einfach mal ob wir dieses
video finden können ich habe jetzt
einfach mal inkognito browser bekommen
das heißt einfach ein browser wollten
noch in keiner eingespeicherten sachen
von mir sind das heißt wir geben einfach
mal konkreter 1
ok es wäre blöd wenn wir was unter com
sind weil das video heißt ja gar nicht
kommen crafter wir geben einfach mal
hott schienbein irgendwie so und sehen
schon
wir haben aber ich will jetzt ganz weg
welche komische zeiten hier drauf geben
wir schauen jetzt einfach mal explizit
nach diesem video und zwar der titel ist
ja thurman team bondi beach euro und ein
punkt punkt punkt aber ich weiß noch
dass er damals geschrieben hatte dass
das ex inter steht ein paar sekunden
später also wenn ich das jetzt hier bei
google eingegeben habe dann kommt hier
tatsächlich noch immer nichts von google
wir sehen nur als reaktion auf ein
rechtliches er ursachen das an google
gestellt wurde haben wir ein ergebnis
von dieser seite entfernt okay
vielleicht wird das video auch schon
entfernt dass ich mein die mail und die
ersten mails ich halte meinen hut zu
bekommen sind auch schon fast ein monat
her ich wollte da halt nur eigentlich
nie ein video zu machen weil ich dachte
okay das ist so ein bisschen zum
randthema ich meine ich gucke einfach
dass es wieder entfernt wird ist wurde
aber irgendwie nicht entfernt und jetzt
habe ich immer mehr anfragen und mails
bekommen von wegen luca reagiert er doch
mal drauf wie ich bin gerade nochmal
durch meine mail ordner durchgegangen
und habe dort noch eine andere mail
gefunden die wir vor einiger zeit
ebenfalls zu dem thema geschickt wurde
hallo luca in meiner google suche nach
dir ist mir was aufgefallen was dich
interessieren könnten und zwar war ich
wie schon erwähnt auf google unterwegs
und habe dich giegold ich weiß nicht was
der film deutschunterricht damals hatte
dabei kamen mir eine seite sehr seltsam
vor ich verlinke sie die am ende der e
mail vorweg möchte ich darauf hinweisen
dass diese seite leicht verstören kann
auf jeden fall ist das ein video von dir
wo du am strand war es leider kenne ich
dieses video selbst nicht von dir und
müsste etwas älter sein ich denke nicht
dass das video dort etwas verloren hat
und will die mit dieser e-mail das sagen
und dann hat er mir halt auf jeden fall
ein link nach unten in die mehrere
eingepackt und ich würde sagen freunde
wir klicken jetzt einfach mal auf den
link drauf da ist tatsächlich mein video
auf dieser website und es hat 141 wollt
ihr mich verarschen
wir schauen jetzt einfach mal kurz rein
aber ihr hört den ton
es ihm schlecht über das kamera mikrofon
weil ich kann mit quicktime kein ton von
meinem macbook auf wenn man sich auf das
ist in ordnung
auf einigen meiner instagram der gesehen
habe bin ich gerade im urlaub und da
habe ich sehr viele leute gefragt wieso
ein typischer tag in meinem bruder pau
sieht deswegen habe ich mir gedacht dies
nehme ich einfach mal kompletten tag
lang mit sei nicht besonders weil ich
nicht so ein grosses habe jetzt mal ganz
im ernst an den user der das blut aid da
steht sogar der name [ __ ] you
der video 45 ich dachte jetzt vielleicht
das hat 200 oder irgendwie so also leute
dieses video ist wirklich ein zu eins
das video was ich damals hochgeladen
hatte von wegen ein tag in meinem urlaub
oder irgendwie so
da hat sich wohl einfach einer irgendwie
das zusammen teller angeguckt und dachte
okay ich mag den typen ich lade einfach
mal das video unter den platz auf einer
homosexuellen website für nicht
minderjährige hoch warum jetzt kommt die
höhe ich habe gerade auf die kommentare
darauf geklickt
der erste kommentar den ich dort sehe
award for peace robert lee der user mit
dem namen core crafter schreibt das ist
geschafft warum heißt über warum kommen
schafft auf dieser webseite schließt man
eben hier die website bevor irgendwelche
viren oder somit darunter lade also
leute ich möchte mit diesem video hier
auf keinen fall werbung für diese
website oder für andere webseiten
solcher art machen ich möchte euch nur
sagen ja da hat wohl wirklich jemand
einfach mal ein video heruntergeladen
auf dieser komische website hochgeladen
und ja ich habe es mitbekommen also ihr
braucht mir das jetzt nicht meine ganze
mailorder damit voll spam wenn ihr
dieses video gerade weht kann es sein
dass das video schon entfernt wurde von
dieser website
weil ich das jetzt schon einmal manager
weitergeleitet habe also ich hoffe das
ist jetzt nicht mehr verfügbar sein
sollte trotzdem großen danke dass sie
mich darauf hingewiesen habe weil ich
meinen das video hat jetzt mittlerweile
auch schon 45.000 aufrufe gesammelt ich
dachte jetzt wirklich dass da
irgendwelche komischen aufnahmen von mir
sind aber das hat wirklich eine einfach
mein video runtergeladen von youtube und
hat es dort auf dieser komischen website
hochgeladen so an sich nicht weiter
schlimm ich nehme es als kompliment also
wenn da jemand schreibt german bei dann
ist es halt einfach ein kompliment an
mich dass er mich wahrscheinlich mag
oder so aber es ist halt wie gesagt ein
urheberrechtsverletzungen deswegen werde
ich sagen wahrscheinlich unternehmen
lassen trotzdem würde ich sagen wenn
euch dieses video hier gefallen hatte
nicht eventuell unterhalten konnte dann
lass gerne leiden gleich findet jetzt
hier eine 2 die eingeblendet wenn ihr
darauf hier könnt ihr meinen kanal
kostenlos abonnieren verpasst keine
videos mehr da oben findet ihr auf
meinen job eingeblendet in dem am ersten
sechsten unter anderem wieder ein wenig
besser sein wir doch noch ein paar
andere sachen kommen werden die long
sleeve die show et cetera und hier und
ist ein anderes video mit ihm all
verabschiedet